alex wood former dodger 30 year old
left-hander 5-0 with a 175 era 35
strikeouts only nine walks he is making
his seventh start of this season this is
the first time he'll face the dodgers
since 2015 when he was with the atlanta
braves he's 2-0 the 193 era in five
games three starts against his former
team lucky bets to stand in as we begin
four pitch walk to start the game very
unusual for
alex wood the dodgers were the base
runner here now is chris taylor swung on
it as he struck him out
back to that slider down around the
knees and that's a big pitch so there is
one away and here now is justin turner
wearing it as he struck it out with the
slider
running down and in and out of the
strike zone back-to-back strikeouts for
wood after the lead-off walk albert
pujols at the plate swinging a hard
ground ball one quick hopkin longoria at
third he slings it over to salado at
second and after a shaky beginning that
four pitch walk to bets wood settles in
very nicely on the hill tonight four the
dodgers will be the right-handed veteran
trevor bauer bauer in his eighth year at
the big league level six one 205
boundaries 30 years of age and nine
starts 4-2 with a 2-2-0 era with 77
strikeouts and 14 walks
first pitch swinging for mikey
and left field chris taylor taylor able
to make the catch one guard very good
beginning for trevor bauer bauer to face
buster poses what's this one to right
bets is there front number two brandon
crawford one ucla bruin facing another
here three-two pitch swan gonna miss
strike three
got him with a fastball and crawford out
on strikes one two three go the giants
in the bottom of the first both these
starting pitchers going according to
their current plans bauer dominating
with the fastball all three outs so
here's belt and it is right there call
strike three guccione rings them up on
strikes and brandon belt
walking back to the third base dugout in
disbelief second strikeout and a
fastball from bauer one gone into second
breaking ball swinging to miss strike
three third strikeout for bauer dodgers
about to get their second look at alex
wood as smokey beth stands in i drive to
left center field
and splits the gap and off of the glove
of tuckman bets to get into second bets
has been on both times dodgers are the
man in scoring position for the first
time tonight and here's chris taylor 2-0
taylor digs it out flies it to center
tuckman's back at the wall it's gone
a screamer to dead center
a two run shot for chris taylor and it's
two nothing dodgers my oh my nice little
setup for a shutdown inning for trevor
bauer talkman woodyastremski
buys the first pitch to right center
field
peters
one dog alex wood left-handed pitcher
right-handed hitter
fastball gets him will says it can't
take a little inventory on that location
being called a strike
the fourth for bauer inside corner
cotton call strike three one two three
go the giants in the third wood is doing
what he wants to do getting the ball to
the ground but one of them kind of a
tough luck base hit this one just finds
its way into center
dodgers with runners at the corners in
one hour they got bat here for dj peters
for the pitcher on deck
he struck it out and he got him to chase
a little bit but close enough and that's
a big strikeout now you have a chance to
kill the inning with the pitcher coming
up
crawford
to salado for the fourth shot on noisy
and the inning is over giants who have
just one hit against trevor bauer
through three innings strikes out
crawford with a high fast ball six
strikeouts for bauer two men out on the
bottom of the fourth so here's belt
shadow left field
turner out taylor in still going it's in
there
belt to second a double gives evan
longoria a chance here representing the
tying run in the bottom of the fourth
bauer home with another 02.
fastball
ball
trevor thought he made the perfect pitch
and dropped his head and started walking
in the dugout he doesn't take it's his
first year with the dodgers looks like
he's been in hollywood for years so
longoria ends up drawing the walk and
now the tying run is aboard with two men
out and alex dickerson coming up did he
go check swing yes he did and bauer puts
the sword away he strikes out dickerson
his seventh strikeout of the game first
and second with one away dodgers again
this is a fourth straight in and they've
had multiple runners on here comes the
future hall of famer albert pujols into
the hole crawford to second
out double play
wow
the gold lover does it again
brandon crawford with an incredible
start to that double play walk dj peters
to get to trevor bauer but where's
trevor bauer i'll tell you johnny's a
good villain you take that long to get
on the field as a hitter it should be
0-2 when you get to the batter's box i
agree trevor bauer who's over 16 is a
hitter that's a base hit to right field
yes throws to first i take it back it's
not a base hit
he grounds out to yastrimsky in right
field and the crowd is going to love
that they're going to absolutely love
that guy's struggling to have base
runners tonight but in this inning
trevor has given them both the walk
tying runs aboard for the giants dodgers
up two nothing he'll have to face evan
longoria here off the glove of bauer he
retrieves it
and he throws off the bag yes strimski
scores and trevor bowers
he was styling he set himself he took
some extra time and then he threw it
away are you kidding me
two to one dodgers and on the tying run
at third the go ahead run in second and
alex dickerson at the plate
[Applause]
right center field into the deepest part
of the park betts with a call on the
catch and the inning is over trevor
bauer back out there at 113 pitches so
he won the argument with dave roberts
he's talked him into it his career high
127. digs deep and strikes him out
96 to finish off his 11th k trevor bauer
six in the third 126 pitches the most
thrown in a big league game this year he
leaves with a 2-1 lead
paying homage to tommy lasorda as he
heads back into the dugout in his first
dodger giant rivalry game with kelly
jansen having pitched three of the last
four days it's blake trining for the
ninth inning one more out ottoman
savannah will try and keep things alive
for the giants
zo one pitch
that's a dodger w tonight in san
francisco and they've cut the lead in
the division to a game